[Música]
día clave para mandatarios
latinoamericanos en la primera jornada
de la asamblea general número 77 de
naciones unidas- el presidente de
colombia gustavo petro pidió acabar con
la guerra contra las drogas que calificó
de irracional mientras que el jefe de
estado argentino alberto fernández
volvió a condenar el intento de
asesinato contra la vicepresidenta
cristina fernández
naciones unidas- señaló a los organismos
de inteligencia venezolanos de
torturaron maltratar a decenas de
detenidos según el más reciente informe
las agencias son parte de un mecanismo
gubernamental para reprimir a la
oposición y perpetuarse en el poder
ampliamos desde caracas
un colectivo de abogados en eeuu demandó
al gobernador del estado de florida ron
de santis por enviar a medio centenar de
migrantes sin recursos y con falsas
promesas a la isla de martha's vineyard
en massachusetts el caso se investiga en
texas donde se encontraban los migrantes
que fueron transportados
bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy valentina torres sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos iniciamos en
nueva york' porque se llevó a cabo la
primera jornada y la asamblea general
número 77 de naciones unidas- la sesión
de apertura contó con una fuerte
presencia de américa latina' en su
primera participación en este escenario
el mandatario chileno gabriel boric se
solidarice se solidarizó con ucrania y
criticó los efectos de la guerra también
fue la primera vez que gustavo petro el
jefe del estado colombiano se pronunció
en la asamblea general donde centró su
mensaje en la crisis climática y la
guerra contra las drogas que calificó de
irracional marina sardiña nos amplía
más allá del unánime rechazo a la guerra
de ucrania los jefes de estado
latinoamericanos pusieron el foco
internacional en las múltiples
problemáticas que sufren sus poblaciones
no existe ninguno de los dos ni derechos
humanos ni democracia cuando la
preservación de los privilegios en unos
pocos se hace a costa del incumplimiento
efectivo de los derechos económicos
sociales y culturales de las mayorías la
guerra contra las drogas como parte de
los discursos de los presidentes de perú
bolivia y en especial colombia gustavo
petro habló de fracaso no solo de la
lucha contra el narcotráfico sino
también de la pelea contra el
calentamiento global yo les demandó
desde aquí desde mi latinoamerica herida
acabar con la irracional guerra contra
las drogas
disminuir el consumo de drogas no
necesita de guerras de armas
necesita que todos construyamos una
mejor sociedad algo que contrasta con el
mensaje del ultraderechista y air
bolsonaro que negó la deforestación de
la selva amazónica brasileña
la mayoría de brasileña un área
equivalente a europa occidental más del
80% de la selva permanece intacta tocar
en contra de lo que informan los medios
de comunicación nacionales e
internacionales los mensajes de los
líderes izquierdistas de la región
tuvieron un claro tono de colonial
apelando a la migración las brechas e
inequidades propiciadas por lo que
calificaron de injusticia neoliberal del
norte global las naciones pobres del
mundo
ya no soportamos
golpe de estado
no soportamos el uso de los bears ni
revoluciones de colores
usualmente
organizadas
para exfoliar
nuestros vastos recursos naturales
américa latina' pidió así en este primer
día de asamblea la unión regional
necesitábamos una voz unidad de américa
latina necesitamos más trabajo conjunto
desde el sur global
naciones unidas- publicó un informe en
el que denuncia que decenas de personas
han sido víctimas de torturas y
maltratos en centros de detención de los
servicios de inteligencia venezolanos el
texto asegura que tanto el servicio
bolivariano de inteligencia nacional
como la dirección general de
contrainteligencia militar son parte de
un mecanismo diseñado para ejecutar el
plan gubernamental de reprimir a la
oposición y apuntalarse en el poder
daniela zambrano corresponsal de france
24 en caracas nos dijo qué conclusiones
arroja el texto y qué reacciones se han
producido
una de las principales conclusiones que
arrojó este informe es que el estado
venezolano utiliza el servicio de
inteligencia para reprimir a la
disidencia y a la oposición esto incluye
crímenes de lesa humanidad también
torturas y delitos sexuales señalando a
los órganos del servicio bolivariano de
inteligencia y de la dirección de
contrainteligencia militar siendo los
principales responsables otra de las
conclusiones es que los funcionarios de
estos organismos no actuaron de manera
independiente y aislada sino por el
contrario respondían a órdenes directas
de altos funcionarios del gobierno
señalando directamente al presidente
nicolas maduros es para el frente de
este plan para reprimir a la oposición
también registró el informe las
violaciones de derechos humanos
cometidas en la zona del arco que generó
en el estado bolívar en la que la
población es víctima de los
enfrentamientos entre cuerpos de
seguridad del estado y grupos
irregulares por el control del oro llama
la atención además que se señalará a
directamente al presidente nicolás
maduro también al director de la 20a al
director del servicio bolivariano
inteligencia y al vicepresidente del
partido socialista unido de venezuela
diosdado cabello directamente como
responsables hubo reacciones por parte
de organizaciones no gubernamentales de
derechos humanos y también de dirigentes
políticos opositores que coinciden en
que este informe el tercero de la misión
internacional independiente de
determinación de hecho de venezuela de
la onu que esto no hace sino ratificar
las denuncias que ellos han hecho en los
últimos años con respecto a crímenes de
lesa humanidad recordemos que este
informe recoge denuncias desde el año
2014 se espera que el próximo 26 de
septiembre sea presentado ante el
consejo de seguridad de derechos humanos
de la onu
vamos a eeuu porque la organización
lawyers force civil rights presentó una
demanda colectiva contra el gobernador
del estado de florida al republicano ron
de santis quien ordenó el envío de medio
centenar de migrantes venezolanos a la
isla de martha's vineyard en
massachusetts la semana pasada el
documento indica que los migrantes
incluidos mujeres y niños fueron
transportados de manera fraudulenta y
discriminatoria con promesas falsas de
trabajo y educación para los niños y
asistencia en inmigración mientras tanto
en texas el sheriff del condado de béxar
anunció la apertura de una investigación
criminal tras el envío de los
indocumentados desde la ciudad de san
antonio
queremos saber qué fue lo que se les
prometió que firmaron si es que firmaron
algo entendieron siquiera el documento
que les pusieron delante sí firmaron
algo esto es estrictamente una medida
depredadora alguien que viene y se
aprovecha de las personas que están aquí
ocupándose de sus propios asuntos y que
están aquí legalmente sin molestar a
nadie pero alguien consideró adecuado
venir de otro estado casarlos
aprovecharse de ellos y luego aprovechar
su situación desesperada sólo por el
bien del teatro político solo por el
hecho de hacer algún tipo de declaración
y poner en peligro en la vida de las
personas el censo de brasil por primera
vez incluye una pregunta que abarca a
los miembros de los denominados
quilombos unas comunidades creadas en
diferentes partes del país por personas
esclavizadas que escaparon de los
trabajos forzados el reconocimiento
demográfico se da en un momento clave en
la reivindicación de las personas
afrodescendientes en brasil cuando en
octubre no sólo se elige a un nuevo
presidente sino también a gobernadores y
dice es un número récord de personas
afro se presentaran a estos cargos
manuel acá no tiene los detalles
y acabar con el vacío en las
estadísticas para cambiar la realidad el
censo brasileño incluye una pregunta que
abarca a los miembros de los llamados
quilombos por primera vez en sus 132
años de historia
aparecer en los números de la
composición demográfica del país es otro
paso hacia el reconocimiento de los
descendientes de las personas
esclavizadas que escaparon de los
trabajos forzosos para crear estas
comunidades aisladas y autosuficientes y
comprobar que la verdad ya se está vida
para nosotros es verificar lo que en
realidad ya se sabe cuántos somos dónde
vivimos y que producimos y producimos
temasek hay una telera intencionada para
que no salgamos en las estadísticas ni a
ninguna encuesta levantamiento name el
proceso que busca romper con parte de su
invisibilización histórica se ha tomado
las calles de y la de mari
uno de los 6000 territorios reconocidos
como quilombos en brasil allí sus
habitantes esperan que el proceso derive
en mejores servicios sociales en
políticas públicas que los incluyan pero
su reivindicación no sólo radica en el
censo ante las elecciones estatales y
federales de octubre paralelas a las
presidenciales se presentan un número
récord de candidatos afrodescendientes
un paso para revertir las estadísticas
actuales
de los 513 legisladores elegidos para la
cámara baja del congreso en 2018 menos
de una cuarta parte se identificaron
como negros
de nada sirve querer derrocar a
bolsonaro y mantener a los diputados y
alcaldes que responden de la misma
manera y de nada sirve poner a un
presidente pensando que será el salvador
de la patria si no cambia todo el
congreso o show la paz en
los comicios de octubre parecen marcar
otro punto de inflexión para encontrar
una mayor representación de la población
afrodescendiente en brasil una que ha
sido silenciada en múltiples momentos de
su historia incluso después de 1888
cuando se convirtió en el último país en
acabar con la esclavitud fin del
informativo volvemos en breve
[Música]